what are the bands that just uh blow
your mind I mean what's your go-to these
days the go-to these well Queens of the
Stone Age yes is always sort of like the
the primary one for me just because
there's so there's no one else like them
and they're they're just so so different
every time but you know I I I'm also
just uh of such a I I've reached that
point where I am so excited just to find
anything new even if it's old
it's new if it's new to me like just
that excitement of finding a band or
finding an album or finding a song like
that's that's kind of like the other
there's the laughs
that that I'm always looking for and
that high and then there's the the other
one of finding just something new to
obsessive I didn't real I mean I I
realized it at the time I didn't take it
for granted but for you know almost 30
years I had this steady stream of
bands being yeah you know I'd show up to
work and I'd be like who are these guys
their name's Green Day yeah we'll see if
I make it you know and and they would
perform eight feet from me and then I'd
walk over and thank them and I get to
see them at rehearsal but uh so many you
know so many bands would come in and and
they were brought in every day yeah that
I didn't have to go out looking for
music yeah and then in the last year or
so I noticed what's going on something's
missing like something Primal and
important is missing from my life and
um my wife said well you really don't
talk to the children I said that's not
it
money
[Laughter]
so anyway marriage isn't going well uh
that's good good God I hate to give you
that but no I totally understand what
you're saying because you you were in a
position where your your job right
involved some band having to sit around
all day long because it's not like the
actors that come in about an hour before
their the show's about to that band is
there pretty much all day long and at
some point they're watching you run your
jokes and you always had your guitar and
you're always playing your guitar it's
like you you were in an environment that
was actually nurturing of musicians and
like you were able to soak that up as
much as they were here oh I was just in
in heaven but what what I did do my my
daughter is uh who's just turned 19 but
uh when she was 18 uh she loves music
and she's a musician and she said
um she really wanted to go to coach and
so I she said you want to come along and
I said yes I'll go to Coachella and it
was such an eye-opening experience for
me because I didn't know a bunch of the
bands and
um she educated me she said okay here
are all the bands we could listen to
that's great and so she uh played for me
all this different music and I'd be like
wait who are these people she said well
that's that's uh you know Japanese
breakfast and I was like wow they're
they're really great well we're gonna go
see them then and then she'd play
another band in another band and so
um it was I saw some people that I knew
uh of course or people that I had heard
of but I saw a lot of music
uh and and you know you're standing
there with a lot of other people most of
them barely clothed uh were you also
wearing like a Native American headdress
and skimpy clothing well because that's
what I understand this is the one time I
didn't do that oh I was wearing his
Spanx yeah I was no uh it was uh it was
the amount of near nudity that I saw was
um and and you do start to feel like a
librarian like
maybe they should try clothing you know
you're like take it easy old man so I
didn't want to be that guy yeah you know
what I mean I wanted to so I was like oh
look you know there's someone's ass but
that's cool that evening did you say
that I did oh geez hey there's an ass no
wait that's not what I do don't do those
things either no don't say that I'm not
supposed to do that have you gone to
Coachella I have I haven't gone to
Coachella in a very long time though I I
hate to admit it I I mean I remember
going there was a good stretch there
when I went pretty much every year I
think you and I are going together ooh
what if we went together let's let's
play I'm in great are you coming to play
no he's just gonna film it I mean he'll
be there but he's just gonna film it can
you monetize it
no my phone's totally charged guys I'm
definitely filming you doing all of this
stuff yeah we're saying they're selfies
but they're taken from 60 feet away yeah
exactly and then we have to fake that I
have really long arms but like I mean
concerts in general and festivals like I
I love going to shows like that was one
of the things that I really that really
did me in with the pandemic is like
taking like live music and concerts away
and like that was Soul crushing for me
for for those
two two years three how many years I
don't even 18 years 18 years nobody even
knows anymore but I will say this and it
made me sad but I really wanted to bring
it down yeah
well I was gonna mention the crash of
the Hindenburg so we just but you beat
me to it with
that's my that's my go-to for what you
know it was about
to display in Lakehurst
but in Flames come on wait what are we
talking about uh no but um I didn't know
it was about to dock yeah oh yeah oh
it's just about to dock yeah it was so
close yeah
that's the tragedy of it
I made it all the way yeah yeah it made
it all the way and it was just docking
when all of a sudden you know maybe
static electricity or maybe I didn't
know that yeah oh that sucks you're so
close wait a minute it sucks you think
it sucks now
so son I'm obsessing on the crash of the
Hindenburg that sucks oh they were so
close prior to this were you like no big
deal they had it coming or what no I
thought he was just like uh we're on
their way and then oh man
that's right Titanic was like halfway
they were on their way and oh man
it's happened within five blocks of the
home yeah that makes it worse you're so
close yeah most it's statistically most
accidents happen within several feet
feet of the dirigible landing spot
true
together and watch uh and and you know
but it's one of the things I was going
to mention that made me sad is that
during the pandemic young people
that I'd be talking to would say I guess
I'll never see a concert again and they
would mean it oh yeah now because
they being older I had the I was able to
say I think with some Authority yes this
is a bad thing that's happening right
now and it's too bad but this will pass
because when you totally when you've
lived a while you see that things happen
and even when they feel like they're
never going to go away they do tend to
move on but people in their early 20s
would be telling me you know
um yeah it's too bad I guess no more
concerts no more comedy shows and I
would say no no they're they're it's
coming back absolutely they just had
such a young perspective yeah that if
you're in your late in your teens and
this pandemic hits you think well that's
it I guess we'll just all live indoors
maybe they're not comfortable like you
know going in a mosh pit anymore or like
you know I think I think we're gonna go
right back to what we were doing okay
exactly yeah but I mean adults had a
similar thing it was just like well I
guess we'll never use the valet again
just bitter that they had to find out my
turn to say that now I gotta Parker I
got a park sucks
and no one else is parking
my tricked out Bugatti it's the same
yeah that's what I drive around I gotta
Park three blocks away now great
I got a Bugatti and I had uh several
different hood ornaments put on the
front one on top of the other all hidden
birds
and a Kaiser's helmet laughs